hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
i'm a property investor and on this
video i'm going to be interviewing a guy
called raza who's from iran but he moved
to the uk and he's built up a property
empire and you're going to be learning
how he did it and also along the way
learning the tricks the tips so that you
can do the same thing too so raza thank
you so much for coming down to my house
thank you so much samuel thanks for
inviting me and so excited to start this
show and
help as much as people we could now
people may remember you because i very
first met you as a letting agency
because when i was looking for a
property for one of my students to live
in and we found this beautiful penthouse
apartment in in the canary wharf
overlooking london and when we came to
view it um you were the agent and i
didn't know who you were but you knew
who i was yeah and i was pretty sh
shocked i was like what someone else
called me what time was this doing here
but yeah that was the first one
back in the day when i met you i was
just working out a living agency so
things changed a lot
the last one and a half years till now
you've also you've done training with us
you've invested in training you've done
some of the free training some of the
paid for training um you've used to work
in a bar then let an agency rent to rent
you've built an empire bro so why don't
you just sort of talk through
what you
why you got into property in the first
place what was it you saw about property
that was exciting
i mean i was always excited about
property is something that like i like
it i love it
so i was working on bars trying to find
a way to get into the market but you
know many people they always tell you oh
you can't do it it's like this it's like
that so i just started to explore
youtube and google to see how could i
get into the property
so i think the first video when you i
don't know type on the youtube property
summer list comes up so i started
listening
to your videos
that you talk so it just gives me that
inspiration that
no it's not like that it's not like you
have to know someone or it's not like oh
you shouldn't be educated that much no
you should just go there and ask so fit
out anything just went to an agency so
look i don't know anything i wanna start
would you help me or not
the guy was like yeah start here for two
weeks if you like you
will hire you oh wow so so you just got
a job
in property so you watched some videos
wanted to get in property at the time
what were you doing working in a bar
uh well as soon as
that company told me you could
start a job here i just gave my two
weeks notice two weeks after immediately
today i started bar
tomorrow
i was with that agency for like um i
think less than a year
after that i moved to a letting agency
because the first one was just a service
accommodation company
so yeah in less than a year
moved to a letting agency and then i met
you
in person in person
the inspiration never gone much much
more higher
and then i was like okay so let's try
something else because samuel lee's
telling me that um you don't need money
to start a business so
i knew a couple of people
started ranking ranking them up and
saying
you know it is corona
i don't have money but i know how to do
it would you be happy to give your
properties to me
no deposit no first month rent
i mean it sounds a bit crazy no one
would believe it but i've done it
because at least it had no money so i
was like it's either this or nothing
so obviously many people they laughed
they said no but i think second of the
third person he was like yeah i'll give
you a try i'll give you two houses if
you could get rid of in
less than a month you'll have it
so you're basically just renting houses
and you're getting a free rent period
and no deposit for the first month or
whatever
but you're renting the property how is
that going to make you money just by
renting a house or an apartment i i i
rented hmo properties so
what i've done talk with the landlord i
had a month to either get rid of the
properties and start the business i lose
it so i did my best actually in four
days both houses gone
right so i paid the landlord he was
quite happy
with the methods that i've gone through
and with everything so slowly and slowly
he just gave me more more more
properties
and i think he got nearly 50 properties
that slowly and slowly all of them are
coming to my portfolio i already done
nearly 20 of them wow so so how
financially i'm just trying to work out
how you're making money doing this so
how much profit are you making currently
on average per month at the moment from
doing this i mean
at the moment and make nearly 10k
uh obviously as you know hmos has its
own cost sometimes you need to finish i
sometimes need this that but we make
about 10k but the lowest that i make
these days is 67k it's a guaranteed
hundred percent right which is fantastic
two years ago i used to work in bars and
making one thousand two hundred pounds a
month but now i work
i don't know two days a week
less than that wow and i'm making that
much
and i'm trying not to start the letting
agency so i mean in total it literally
changed my life
in the last two years with just your
videos your classes obviously a little
bit of a research by myself but it's
always started with
you showing and telling people that it's
actually not that hard you just need to
be focused and do it how much how much
did it help you i imagine it helped you
quite a bit but be interested to see
your opinion being a letting agent and
then going into this rental rent
strategy do you think being a latin
agent first did that give you a lot of
uh respect and kudos to people trust you
more because you worked as a latin
agency do you think i mean
that could help because obviously when
you
with a landlord or an investor it gives
them that assurance that you could take
care of the property it gives them that
assurance that
they will know that you know what you're
doing
but
then again if you have no experience on
letting it's just a couple of months are
selling you have to just study do some
courses
and you can start with it but obviously
yeah if you have an experience it works
much much more better
are you buying houses yet i'm planning
to buy my first house i was actually
planning to buy my first house a couple
of months ago but because my weeds are
expiring i can't apply for a mortgage
but this august as soon as i get my new
visa are you are you british
no
um
in a five years visa here oh wow okay
that's why i can't buy anything
otherwise i would have my first house
listed five six months ago but this
august i'm gonna buy my first house
great how does it affect you not being
british being on a work visa does it
affect the rent-to-rent business and
being a property entrepreneur or not
really just if you're buying uh i mean
for the business it's not going to make
any changes i mean it makes make changes
or not to be honest we on one side no if
you want to do the job you could just do
it without anything
but on the other side obviously any
business you need to get mortgages you
need to get loans you need to
do some stuff which yeah if you're not
british
unfortunately you can't do some of this
stuff like the mortgaging or getting
some loans to start up your business so
it was a bit of trouble because many
many people they go they get a startup
business loan and they start their
business but for me because i can't do
that
i have to start the business literally
with zero so you couldn't even get a
business loan
i started my business with 13 pounds
from the company's house and on that day
i was minus 200 on my overdraft wow so
you've got zero money
you've got you're on a work visa
but you've got
courage
experience
yeah i mean it will come honestly like
the first two houses that i mentioned i
literally had no money but in five days
both houses has gone i literally just
collected those people's money gave it
to the landlord and i made nearly a
thousand pounds on it i was like what in
four days i literally made the whole
amount of money that i was making in a
bar
so after that it's just go oh let's
start it i've had two properties then it
becomes three four five six and
obviously here and there i've done some
things like i've done your deal selling
and immediately after i had two deals
that i sold was exactly
what i used to do but you just showed me
that oh yeah i could charge people
actually yeah for finding the deal so i
just sold them the deal and i made my
money back
that's amazing and that's the point when
you invest in yourself the idea is that
you then make the money back because you
can't grow your bank unless you grow
yourself first
yeah i believe that i i believe that the
all of those ones helped me a lot
especially the deal selling
many people say oh it's expensive it's
that it doesn't worth it but no i
believe it is it is you pay for the deal
selling master class two thousand one
thousand nine hundred ninety five pounds
okay so you paid basically two thousand
and how much did you make on the first
deal that you sold uh two thousand and
how long did it take you to sell the
deal
less than two weeks i mean we had some
things going and coming but one of them
i saw the less than two weeks but the
second deal just gone in a day
amazing
so what would you say
to somebody that's in your situation
maybe they're on a work visa or they've
got no money they can't get a business
loan but they're really really desperate
to get into property what would you say
the steps that they should take would be
i would first educate yourself yeah
because i've seen many many many people
not thousands or hundreds of thousands
but 10 20 people that they try to start
the business obviously it works on the
first six months maybe but you lose it
all so
don't start the business
thinking that you could make it thinking
that you could start the business and
then learn later it doesn't work that
way if you lose your trust once you lost
it forever so educate yourself
before going anywhere before doing
anything
and second of all
attend networking like go to networking
events meet people yeah i mean this is
the key honestly you could knew how to
do it
you could have the money
you could know everything but if you
don't have the connections and
networking you don't have anything
honestly all i have now it just came
from my networking yeah i mean i just
didn't sit in my office and someone
called me and say oh this is my house no
i just went to networking events called
landlords went on gumtree facebook i
don't know any group anywhere whoever
has had a property i was out there
asking them yes even they're not giving
their properties to me but they are
landlords so they somehow
managed to be a landlord so they could
help you because you have some idea what
happens if you take your property on a
landlord and it doesn't quite work out
the way you hoped and you can't rent it
out and you're losing money then what do
you do do you have to pay the landlord
up honestly i would do the same myself i
had one one of my houses two tenants
didn't pay i just paid it myself because
so there's risk involved then of course
there is risk involving anything you
could just walk to the street and
someone hit you and die there is a risk
and that as well everything comes with
the risk
depends on you either you could take
that risk
or no say oh no no i don't want to make
a risk i just want to work in a bar or
in the sainsbury's and just you know
leave my life
that's true it's true
how do you prevent that from happening
you've you're making about ten thousand
pounds a month from rent to rent
you've lost money on
some occasions of course but generally
speaking you you normally don't
how do you do your research and your due
diligence to make sure that the property
is definitely going to be a good deal
before you take it one of the first
thing that i've seen many many people
doesn't do you have to
check your area yeah you have to check
to see either in this area for example
if you want to do a hmo we have to see
what type of house we got
what prices we could rent for it and
what type of client are we getting are
we getting uh
i don't know orderly people do we gain
people that they are claiming benefit do
we have students here do we have
professional workers here i myself i
knew there are a lot of risk on those
ones on the students and on every single
person except the professional workers
so what i do myself i only focus on
professional people
yeah i
don't have anyone else in my house as
hundred percent professional people
because i knew they pay up so i'm safe
on that site right and also that's your
market so you you understand the supply
the demand you understand who you're
marketing to the worst thing i've seen
people doing hmos is mixed students and
professionals and benefits that doesn't
work
we took over a portfolio of eight
properties less than two months ago
which the company was about to get
bankrupt they wouldn't even make the
money that they were paying the
landlords
when i took over the portfolio obviously
we have to see their books then i figure
out that they did the same mistake in
one house they have people that they are
students they have people that are
working in a bar and they have
professional people
so this doesn't work at all because the
time frames it's not each other someone
wakes about four a.m someone comes back
or comes they come at 2 am so they
bother each other they have nose the
tenants are not happy they rubbish the
house because they
they're not happy yeah and after a
couple of months they leave you
so you lose your business so you have to
search to see if you want to get a house
what type of client are you getting here
and what prices you're looking for
are you worried about the energy price
increases with your hmos uh i was
worried about it but i've done something
that it saved me a lot of trouble yep
uh good contract you always say that and
easily important you should always have
a good contract to save you on many
sites for example i mean just even a
network provider
they give you an unlimited sim card but
on a fair use if you use a lot they
cancel you unlimited easy
our system is exactly the same we'll
give you old bills included house for
energy
you have to use a fair amount of energy
so what we do for example i just went to
the room this morning
for a house and the bill for that house
is a tree that comes at nearly 120 230
pound a month so what i've done on those
contracts i told them
this house has 150 pound credit limit
for all bills included contract if it's
less than that no problem but if your
bills goes to 200 the tree room should
pay 15 pounds in each why because i had
tenant they are home two hours a day but
the heating is on 22 hours extra because
they don't care you know it's all bills
included they're like okay why should i
care but when i do that first of all
they don't waste energy anymore yeah
they turn it off and second of all
if it goes higher than what i calculate
they will pay for it because i had some
cases that i have to pay nearly 300
pounds a month
on energy while i was just counting 150
so i just done that so you just put a
fair use policy and you say the bills
are included up to this point and if it
goes more then they the other is all and
we are fair about it like for example
for the house that i mentioned the bill
is 120 130 every month so we didn't say
100 we said 150 pounds just even make
sure even if they are
wasting a little bit of energy it's
still all right yeah but if they go
further on the map then they knew that
they have to pay but it's good it's
actually good because since that time
that i changed my contract all my energy
wheels
came
down from what i even expected it right
so yeah this is how i do it so give me
an example in a case today as to you've
got how many how many rental events you
have at the moment
uh 19 19. yeah so and are they all from
the same landlord or multiples
whoa
okay
this is interesting so how does that
landlord feel
about you making 10 grand a month
just off of him what what why would he
not just say actually i'm just gonna
hire somebody and pay him two thousand
pounds a month and get rid of raza
i mean he could do that
but i mean you're a big landlord
yourself
how much your time worth
for you
a lot very very expensive a lot orlando
who has 40 50 properties he is a super
super busy person
he doesn't care if i make 10k or 100k on
this property what he cares to get his
rent
property is taken care of
and not pay any management fee because
think of a big landlord got 50
properties has to at least pay 20 for
management don't they
well i guess if you include the finders
fees
with the turnover of the tenants it's
more than that but they nearly pay 18 to
20 just for management yeah yeah and if
you just multiply that by
50 properties
then you figure out obviously yeah i
make 10k a month but he saves 10k a
month
and not paying the commissions
and he got a rent guarantee for the next
five 10 years but then how do you you
said you only work in a couple two or
three days a week
and it's it's much less hard than it was
when you're in the bar but how do you
how do you how have you managed to
systemize it and
then streamline it to the point you have
because managing 19 hmos
that is crazy like that for a lot of
people that will be three or four
full-time jobs
yeah i mean
i i always try to find a smooth way
around it because i'm a type of guy that
always want to automate my stuff
i don't mind paying people more for it
because i love my time be free so for
example for these ones i obviously got
my team my handymans plumbers this that
so i passed it to my tenants
and they are a trusted team by me i knew
that they're not going to charge me
extra or anything so just told my tenant
don't call me if you have a problem in
your house call my handyman he sorted
that for you he's just sending me the
bill so i have no problem for me and
because you know the handyman the
handyman's not going to go and do a job
that doesn't need doing or an expensive
yeah because you know i pay them a good
money i have a lot of jobs i change a
lot of people when i figure out
yeah they're charging a lot or they're
trying to be funny so
i think what people forget about rent to
rent is that rent to rent is a business
and the most important part to business
is systems procedures processes and if
you don't know how to run the business
even if you get deals people say to me
i'm struggling to get a rent to rent
deal i can't get a rent to rent deal
it's like to be honest you wouldn't be
able to handle a rent to rent deal
i'm glad that you're struggling to get
one because
if it was really easy to just get ready
to rent deals then what would happen is
people would get rent directories but
then they'd mess it up does that make
sense yeah i mean
we had a lot of people if you just
sorry
i wasn't here obviously by that times
but
i do a lot of research on the market to
see how people failed
and uh because i don't want to go those
paths so if you just go back to 2008
2010-12 even before 2016 many many
people did the same yeah just did it but
after five six months they just figure
out oh you know
i can't handle it right
and they lost it all i mean
i know two people
both of them with more than 50
properties they were making nearly 30k a
month each
but they lost the business they
completely lost the business and that
ninth house that i told you was the last
houses that we took from the same
business the same business as making 30k
a month they came to the point
that they couldn't manage to pay their
bills and they have to give their
properties free to us
right take care of it so this is how you
could see like a bad management what can
do to you yes and
i'm just seeing what people does and
fail and i don't do them easy
why do landlords pass their properties
over to rent to rent experts
uh well there are many reasons the first
that i figure it's the management fee
yeah it is really important because many
many landlords they have their
properties and mortgage
and after paying the mortgage and the
management fee nothing gets left so if
they give it to the property management
company at least they knew at the end of
the month they make a little bit of a
money yeah and the second one empty
periods and i came to the market on a
good time
being honest because when i started my
business it was krona time yeah no one
would have come to the hmo business
because no one would have pay rent but
i'll figure out that my area is not like
every area my area is professional area
so where's your area
canary all my houses are in canada
i just do business in kenora and central
london that's it
so i was like okay the time that no one
opens a business i will open a business
it's impossible we're living in london
one of the biggest and
luxurious and i don't know
best cities in the world how come i
can't just start a business and rent a
couple of properties come on it is
ridiculous if i can't do it
it's incredible though that what you've
done to start with nothing in the canary
wharf london one of the most expensive
parts of the uk and should just be like
right i've got no money but i'm gonna
and now
the first time i did didn't have
anything to lose the landlord just gave
me the two properties he said in a month
you have
seven rooms to fill if you feel six
you lost a deal you give me the six
tenants
and you just walk away
i say okay cool just give me a month let
me try so it was a matter of living and
dying for me i was like either i have to
do this
i'm just gonna lose it yeah so i've done
it it worked i moved to the next one and
yeah how much were you getting paid as a
letting agent when you were back in the
day when you had a job as a letting
agent uh i mean a language in uk makes
between 30 to 50k a yeah okay so you
were working in bars getting 1200 a
month
you then thought i want to get into
property you watched my videos
you got some confidence you walked into
some agencies you got a job
a pay increase and then you went from a
letting agent to thinking actually i can
be an entrepreneur
and i can rent properties manage them
myself use the rent to rent strategies
and now you've got 19 properties how
many how many rooms how many units
well we got one bit flat
with two rooms we got
six bed
houses so right so you've got hmos
apartments do you do service
accommodations as well you rent events
uh well i was thinking about doing the
service accommodation but
i just figured out that i don't have the
basis ready yet right
i'm sure that i will do it one day yeah
in central london definitely
but i'm sorry if i forgot that i don't
jump 200 things in one go yeah i want to
finish this one and go to the next one
yeah so i've done the room company it
works perfectly for itself now i'm in
the letting agency yeah hopefully the
next one right okay and i guess service
accommodation as well comes with
different rules different regulations
um so you've kind of just found your
niche and just killed it
yeah because i do believe you could do
anything you could you could move
so fast yeah be as a professional but if
you do it perfectly
you're gonna be okay in it so
i found these two i'm gonna stick to it
for a couple of years
to make it to a level that i think now
it could control itself and obviously
then the next one the next one the next
one it's never finishing um
what do you think in terms of we've
talked a lot about property and skill
set and processes but in terms of person
i think that you've got to have a
certain attitude mentality
in order to win in business it's not
property yes i think property is
probably the best way to make money in
terms of all the different other
strategies i think properties the safest
the most lucrative in my opinion but
what do you think separates
successful people and unsuccessful
people in terms of the person
well i mean
first of all we have to i mean
say it's the person that does all the
job it's your mentality that does all
the job the difference between reza who
works in a bar and the reza who works
in a letting agency it's just that
mentality nothing changed with me no
information came in and went and it's
just
that
and
just single steps about your daily
routine yeah because you can't have a
daily routine that you wake up late you
don't have a good food every day
i don't know you don't educate yourself
you don't study and be like okay i want
to be a successful ceo no you can't be
you can't never be there
for me honestly sometimes my friend used
to say oh you're crazy waking up 5am
and i didn't need honestly to wake up at
5am but i forced myself i said no
i have to wake up at 5am every day i
have to do a little bit of a research
every day i have to do training every
day then go to work yeah
and that made me to become more
successful
because i just put a plan for myself
like kids
that this time i wake up this time i do
this this time i do that and i just
followed the plan that i put for myself
just for three months honestly just for
three months and and that three months
my life changed
so interestingly you say it rather
because when i was at school i wasn't
very good at school but they tell you
right you've got maths for 45 minutes
then you've got english and you've got
this and and you've just got your
classes you've got to do and if you're
that if you're disciplined like that in
your business you don't have to
necessarily work 20 hours a day but if
you just say i'm going to focus i'm
going to get what i need to get done um
i'm going to do the things that need to
be done rather than
twiddling on right move and look i'm
actually going to make the calls pick up
the phone
then it's not hard being successful but
it's also not hard being a loser is this
about choosing which hard you want to
pick
yeah i mean
as you say it's not hard to be any of
those two but if you have just some
planning and
you want to do it it is really important
i i've seen many people that they don't
want to do it
so you first of all you have to have
that mentality in your mind that i want
to do it when i moved to london honestly
i moved to london just in 30 minutes
one day i came back home i woke up my
mom was downstairs in our house in
birmingham
and i just had my bike
she said what are you doing i said you
know what i'm tired of living in
birmingham and in this situation i just
want to go to london so what do you want
to do i said i don't know i want to go
to london i'm sure i could find a way
around it and everyone friends family
everyone they're like oh you're stupid
you're going to one of the most
expensive cities without any plan i was
like no i'm just going there and i find
a flat
just moved to london
and i did my job many people say oh you
can't do it you can't do but i knew it
from the beginning in myself that i can
do it i want to do it and i will do it
that's why since that day i didn't call
anyone else i just told them guys i'm
leaving
when i call you back
i'm someone else and i called some of
them actually back
but i was someone else i was a guy that
all of them think that i can't be
but i made in less than three years
literally i made it less than three
years i mean working in the bar was the
best part when i was in birmingham i was
jobless
easy
but i want to make it and i did it that
sacrifice that you made
having to just walk away from your
friends and family not not more turn
your back on them more but but just
literally
go off and and i mean most people
wouldn't do that most people would want
to be safe they'd want to be in their
comfort zone they'd want to be with
their friends and family just going to
london with no plan when your friends
and family turn your stupid i mean
that's when you see the difference that
some people they are still 70 and they
work in narrators and someone is tea and
has i don't know private yuck or it's
just on a holiday every day or you less
than 40 and you're doing amazing it's
just that risk
that you have to talk with yourself
saying to yourself am i
enough
to take that risk do i believe in myself
it's just that if you believe in
yourself you'll do it
but some people want to do it they tell
you that they want to do it but they
don't believe in themselves
if you just have that belief everything
is done everything is coming i mean like
come on it's the best
city to live in europe and you can't
just
i don't know make a couple of thousand a
month then there's something wrong with
you mate
i agree how much does it cost you to
live do you are you a big spender or are
you saving a lot of that money that
you're making i'm a bigger spender
okay i enjoy my life so how's life
changed then from two three years ago to
now well two three years ago i used to
live in
white chapel
sharing a room with seven more people
uh
couldn't afford to eat that much of a
food and i have to go to iceland and buy
one pound frozen
bolognese
now
i go to best restaurants in the city
uh i buy whatever i want
i go wherever i want and the most
important thing i set my own times if
i'm not in the mood of working today i
just don't work
if i want to work more today
i'll do it so obviously yeah i mean
now i'm in this
level that i'm not worried about rent or
car or if i want to buy anything or if i
want to go holiday
those times passed
now i am in a level that i'm thinking
okay where do i want to buy where do i
want to invest well it's well deserved
bro you deserve every success what's
your strongest reason for doing this
i was always good at business
this is why i think to myself but as a
kid
i tried it many many times with the
friends family to do something and all
the time they were like oh you're a kid
what you want to do like come on just
leave your life life to other people
have a secure job test that and one day
i came to myself i said why no one
believes in me while i never let them
down
so i said to myself
i'm gonna risk it
i'm gonna do it either i can't do it
then i come back and this is what they
say they say you can't do it then i
didn't do it it's nothing going to
change it's still the same things you
know
but if i do it
then i did it for myself
then i changed my life and i never gonna
regret it that i never done it yeah
because this is really bad regret that
you never done it yeah this is divorce
case scenario could happen to you well
dude i'm inspired by your story and i'm
excited to help you move to whole new
levels as well i mean you already helped
help me
what's it been like working with me and
you know sort of i know you've done some
of the training and you a lot of the
networking what's what's the experience
been like the experience been amazing
because uh first i learned a lot about
the business
i learned a lot for example we are
focusing a lot that have a good contract
this this good contract
saved me a lot from
many many losses
and the second of all this energy
this energy that you get you get
motivated you're like yeah come on do it
and one thing i like about it it's like
you're not like
other i don't know
trainers that they tell you okay do this
this this let's do it come back next
week tell me what you did no you're a
type of a guy that you show it to us and
then you force us you're like do it now
and you can't run away like if i be on
my phone someone from like i don't know
hey do this so you have to do it yeah
and when you do it then you figure out
oh it's not that hard you know right so
those classes again helped me to gain
more confidence because after
the deal selling
then i get the inspiration that uh you
know i have to go bigger yeah i just
stuck in
a room for like six months now it's too
much every three months i have to do
something so i was like okay let me
start the letting agency
what's the name of your business
which one
wow your main one
well the main one now is roomsie rooms
we do rooms yeah and it was so funny
because i chose the name in 10 seconds
because when the landlord said yes i
actually does that while i was talking
with him i had the chance to just open
the company
so it was a great name
it is a great name but it is so funny
because i was thinking about the name
for like a couple of months and i had
nothing in mind because i was thinking
about their own business but on that day
because i was under pressure that i have
to give a company name to the landlord
in the next
five ten minutes i just check check
check oh rooms is nice that's great it's
the kind of thing people would spend
three weeks working on but you did it in
three minutes and the second one is the
venti and venti when the unventi i just
like the sound of it but obviously it
shows as we and we
it's like we'll get in touch with you
insta instagram i'll put your instagram
details
in the link below thank you so much well
done my brother i'm so proud of you man
thank you i appreciate it
and yeah i mean the second business
starting obviously we tweak everything
we have everything ready yeah but
officially we not start trading crazily
because
i've got a big landlord that i want to
add so as soon as we have that one then
we're just gonna
so you're about to blow even bigger
let's take that 10 grand a month to 100
grand a month
oh i'm thinking more than that well
i only got a landlord with 200
properties that i want to join just
waiting for me that 200 properties
itself is quarter million business a
year
right so this is my thing that i think
it works perfectly many people they're
just looking for properties and they
don't mind it i don't look for
properties or landlords
look for investors
some people with 200 properties 100
properties that's why i could manage my
time because instead of having 20
properties from 20 different landlords
and calling them every week wasting my
time i have one landlord with 20
properties i call him once a week yeah
that makes sense again it's all about
processing procedures and systems um
time management
love it bro hey guys i hope you enjoyed
that we could chat for hours um i'll
leave his details instagram below in the
in the description also if you want to
come down to a live training class like
rather did you want me to kick your ass
help me get successful in property i'm
gonna leave a link in the in the
description and guess what free tickets
available right now limited spaces so
get booked on
i've been doing these interviews every
single week for the last three years or
so so there's a playlist of like well
over 100 i think it's like 170 people
right now so you can listen to some more
stories be inspired
get booked on this on the free training
and i'll see you next time
[Music]